[Música]
los invito a viajar al año 2050 por
favor
abróchense muy bien sus cinturones
pongan su asiento en vertical y vámonos
para allá va a tomar un instante cierren
los ojos
abramos ya estamos en el 2050 fue algo
rápido pero les tengo una mala noticia
2050 no es un año muy alentador no es un
juego de niños porque tenemos
un récord de hambruna a nivel mundial
nada de lo que se haya visto como en las
décadas pasadas
tenemos 10 mil millones de habitantes
eso es 30% más de lo que teníamos hace
unos instantes 2019 nuestras ciudades
están totalmente saturadas los terrenos
productivos donde tenemos
el ganado ya no es suficiente por tal
motivo pues no hay ganado no hay
proteína para poder alimentar al mundo
siguen las malas noticias estamos ya es
un tema apocalíptico debido al
calentamiento global
a la pesca indebida descontrolada y la
basura ya no tenemos peces en nuestros
océanos ni mucho menos en los ríos todo
esto debido además del calentamiento
global
sumado todo esto ya se pueden imaginar
lo que está sucediendo en cada uno de
los países que conforman nuestro planeta
pobreza y la pobreza genera guerra
de buena suerte que nada más somos
viajeros hacia este año y podemos
regresar al 2019 ya estamos de vuelta
tenemos oportunidad de ser cambio el
cambio tiene que ser de esencia tiene
que ser un cambio mental
y todo debe de estar conectado con la
comida con el alimento que es una parte
inherente de nuestro ser como personas
las definiciones tradicionales de la
comida es cualquier sustancia que sirve
para que seres vivos como los animales
las personas lógicamente las plantas
puedan crecer desarrollarse y sobrevivir
está sabroso el plato ya me da un
poquito de hambre pero bueno vamos hacia
una definición más emocional porque la
comida no es tan técnica la comida es
parte como lo comenté hace unos
instantes una parte muy muy integral de
quiénes somos nosotros yo pienso que la
comida es un universo es como un
universo en la expansión siempre está
cambiando siempre hay nuevas propuestas
también define quienes somos
como buenos norteños que creo que somos
la mayoría bueno pues la conexión a la
carne asada
al cabrito
y nos conecta con nuestros orígenes
lógicamente con el entorno con toda la
parte geográfica a mí me sucede algo muy
particular con el cabrito el cabrito me
transporta siempre mentalmente hacia la
cocina de mi abuela al yo estar
preparando oliendo ahí un gay cabrito al
pastor asado en salsa inmediatamente me
dirijo a la cocina de la abuela y siento
que estoy ahí con ella entonces
esa es la conexión de lo que tenemos con
nuestros alimentos siempre yo estoy
seguro que a cada uno de ustedes se les
dispara eso en la mente y les recuerda
algo a alguien o le recuerda de que del
lugar
de donde vienen
pero lo que yo les quiero invitar en
este momento es replantear nuestra
conexión en el emocional con los
alimentos y explorar diferentes
alternativas
es decir no pensar en cabrito nada más
no pensar en carne asada expander
nuestra mente porque
ese numerito está muy interesante son 2
mil millones dos mil millones son las
personas en el mundo que comen insectos
como parte de su dieta diaria
yo aimar que los que no consideran a los
insectos como tabú ya los que sí
aquí quienes han probado insectos alguna
vez dejen la mano arriba quienes han
probado insectos este último mes
quienes consumen insectos como parte de
su dieta
eres como el 1% de la población entonces
eres de las mías yo ayer me llega y una
de chapulín ese gusanito de maguey
los insectos más consumidos en el mundo
aunque no lo crean son los siguientes
escarabajos orugas avispas abejas
hormigas y chapulines más o menos en ese
orden como quiera pues estamos hablando
de que hay 1900 aproximadamente 1900
especies de insectos comestibles en el
planeta y méjico buenos pues somos muy
fuertes en el consumo de los insectos
tenemos a los chapulines que se han ido
a oaxaca por ejemplo saborcito picosito
limón oso en quesadillas va buenísimo en
una serie de cosas las hormigas
chicatanas a mí a mí también me parecen
deliciosas me recuerdan al chocolate
mexicano el sabor cacao café tostado me
recuerda mucho eso no se digan los
gusanos de maguey que son deliciosos
tienen notas ahumadas se puede hacer en
salsas yo me los como solos mis hijos me
los roban de refrigerios y se los comen
con separan cacahuate y tos
su miles son como unas chinches
chiquitas que tienen un sabor herbáceo
parecido a la menta hierbabuena muy
interesantes también y pues bueno hay
alacranes ahí escamoles hay agua hoteles
un sinfín de cosas
pero además de ser
ingredientes buenos elementos productos
deliciosos
son una maravilla alimenticia porque lo
digo
son altos en proteínas bajas en grasas
altos en fibra ricos en aminoácidos
calcio zinc
tienen definitivamente muchos puntos
positivos son realmente lo que le llaman
super food es un súper superalimento
los beneficios del medio ambiente son
deliciosos hay beneficios para las
personas también lo son para el medio
ambiente no requieren de mucho cuidado
para sobrevivir generan menos gases
invernadero al estar comiendo insectos
estás comiendo el 100% del insecto
cuando comemos vaca o puerco u otra pues
hay mucho desperdicio
además de esto la producción es 20 veces
más eficiente
al estar trabajando con los insectos hay
menos producción de metano lo que es muy
bueno también para nuestro medio
ambiente sobre bien del desperdicio
orgánico casi casi es controlar muy bien
sus elementos para que haya una
supervivencia y un crecimiento muy
adecuado para los fines que estamos
buscando que es convertirlos en alimento
también como último punto para producir
un kilo de proteína de insectos se
requiere 2 kilos de alimento y en cambio
en los ganados son las proteínas
tradicionales se requieren 8 kilos para
producir 1
entonces
qué necesita él es mi hijo está por allá
mateo y ahorita lo saludamos que
necesitamos hacer o hoy para salvar al
mundo
pensemos pensemos que hay que hacer
de entrada hay que liberarnos de los
estigmas de pensar que los insectos son
animales rastreros bueno si lo son
de que andan en la basura algunos pero
otros no
de que son causantes de plagas que
aparecen en el apocalipsis todo eso pero
hay que quitar hay que quitar esos
tapujos y verlos como amigos y no
enemigos
realmente si son una fuente alternativa
de proteínas estudios en las últimas
décadas han demostrado de que de que los
insectos si son una manera de evitar que
día a día mueran miles de personas y
esto va
creciendo de manera desproporcionada
hay que seguir promoviendo la
investigación la difusión por eso estoy
aquí platicando les de mis insectos
desarrollaron nuevas técnicas para poder
que controlar más su crecimiento su
producción toda la parte salubre
puedes lograr
al mismo tiempo productos amigables eso
es lo que yo estado haciendo en los
últimos años utilizo sales chiles
especias
mo lícitos los insectos los íntegro a
las sales pues para así ir
concientizando a la población del
consumo de de los insectos aunque bueno
esto sea los insectos se han consumido
desde los inicios del tiempo
pero bueno lo más importante es de que
las nuevas generaciones inspiren a las
mismas generaciones y a las que vienen
por delante aquí están mis hijos le voy
a poner un pequeño videíto de algo que
sucedió hace un par de días en su
humilde casa que tienen proteínas
ensaladita y saben como un cacahuate
pruébalo te va a gustar tiempo
sí
t
y bueno este aceite lo comen
ándale mateo
sabor el sabor
y traga
me gusta
estoy diciendo mentira virna del fin
degustación o qué
pato el mayor está tratando de convencer
el que coma gusanos de maguey que
también se conoce como nombre de
chinicuila y pues ahí mateo ya pueden
ver su cara de felicidad de que le gustó
mucho y pato del lado izquierdo pues
está ahí platicando le de todas las
bonanzas beneficios bueno
dejen ustedes los beneficios son bien
ricos es como si a quien no le gusta el
puerco bueno muy poquita persona pero
bien cocinado al o sea todo bien
cocinado sabe bien rico entonces eso es
bien importante
solamente me resta decir
comamos insectos para así poder salvar
al mundo muchas gracias
[Música]